in our collaboration with kaiser Health
News in NPR we're taking a look at
surprise medical bills that catch many
Americans off-guard CDC estimates the
biggest chunk of the nation's three
point three trillion dollar health care
bill is for chronic illness that
accounts for 90% of the total costs one
of those conditions multiple sclerosis
affects more than 2.3 million people
without treatment the neurological
disease can cause disability the latest
bill of the month reveals just how
costly life-saving drugs can be Charice
Hickson was bedridden with MS symptoms
at one point unable to work or care for
her nine-year-old little boy
after trying to other drugs a single
mother's doctor prescribed an infusion
called okra vus now it cost sixty five
thousand dollars a year Medicare and
Medicaid paid for nearly all of her
previous treatments so she was very
surprised when she was billed more than
3600 dollars for the first two doses of
this new medicine when I received the
veal and it said three thousand dollars
pay immediately and I'm like where am I
supposed to get this from I'm on
disability and that would be five months
of my checks
several weeks after calling the
Cleveland Clinic and a PHA and applying
brother for financial assistance
Charice's balance was zeroed out but she
still worries about charges for the
treatments two times a year in the high
cost of drugs for others with MS the
editor-in-chief of kaiser Health News
dr. Elizabeth Rosenthal is with us at
the table to discuss so help us
understand what happened to Charisse
because she got two infusions they cost
123 thousand dollars a year but why our
infusion drugs let's start with that so
expensive
well because infusion drugs come with
all these associated costs you can't
take them at home I mean you go to the
hospital or an infusion clinic and
you're in a bed so basically they're up
coated or up charged so it's not just
the drug it's the whole shebang you're
paying for so that's a that's an
important thing before she's been on
drugs she could take it home and
Charisse has worked in medical billing
which I also think is interesting but
even she was caught off guard with
getting 3600 I think Elizabeth people to
think if it normally cost 123,000 and
you get charged 30
six-hundred isn't that sort of a deal
well that that higher price is just kind
of a notional price right and a thirty
six hundred dollar bill for any of us
suddenly dropping in your box is a lot
it's a huge amount you know your kid
doesn't go to summer camp or door you
know you don't get those gym lessons you
wanted to do and basically why she was
so surprised is she'd been on 2ms drugs
they're all really expensive but she'd
never paid anything before and part of
the problem was that now she's on an
infused drug and that comes with all of
these big charges he's the moral of this
story though call up and ask about
financial assistance because the
Cleveland Clinic takes care of people
they have a pretty liberal policy in
terms of taking care of people who don't
have the means to pay don't they they do
all hospitals have what are called
financial assistance or the charity care
programs but they're not going to offer
those up to you they're there in the
paperwork somewhere they may be in one
of those folders so you have to ask you
have to say is there financial
assistance for me and so she did the
right thing she picked up the phone and
said I can't pay this bill what can I do
and the thing to remember is medical
care is so expensive in this country and
even if you make a decent income you may
be eligible and there's a lot of
discretion that the hospitals have dr.
Rosenthal we would never go to a store
and purchase a piece of clothing or a
piece of food without looking at the
price or order at a restaurant why is it
that we go to the doctor we are
prescribed and order up treatments and
medication that we have no idea what
they cost well that's a big problem to
me right we should we should be able to
no and no one told her I mean what the
doctors the important--is doctors aren't
cost conscious about this either he's
just thinking there are 12 drugs to
treat MS they're all pretty good the one
she's on isn't working so well let's try
X but he's not thinking oh my god exit
calls an infusion and that's gonna leave
my patient vulnerable to all these other
charges probably she does know broken I
don't think she's one bit no I don't
either because I have insurance through
CBS through unitedhealthcare
I go my kids get preventive care and I
still get a bill over a thousand dollars
and that's for preventative care I mean
that's not even for a life saver
drugged and you still get so every time
you can Tassadar well how much is it
gonna cost for you to take my child's
temperature or how's it gonna cost to do
the blood pressure right and I think if
she'd asked her doctor how much has it's
been a classified change to this new
drug he would have said I don't worry
about it I don't know I'm sure it's the
same as you need one you need and and
you know he or she probably doesn't know
either the system is so broken so
dysfunctional and you know I love this
series so how do we find out though how
do you know you're saying doctor so how
do we find out the doctor did well she
could try to go to Cleveland Clinic and
say how much is this gonna cost but that
said you know she's a sick person she's
barely get out of bed she wants to be
treated she's supposed to do like
investigative journalism with Cleveland
Clinic so I think you know in other
countries there are binding estimates
when you need a new treatment it's not
it doesn't take detective work that we
should want that to so I don't blame her
for not asking in advance because we're
also kind of oh my god they're not gonna
tell me they won't know I'm just gonna
I'm just gonna try and do what's right
for my health I have good insurance to
start where some robberies do in the
future and if you have a choice between
an infusion drug which is more expensive
or a pill you should opt for the pill if
you can right right I think that's one
of the lessons that infusions come with
all these costs for many many illnesses
there's a choice of an injection or an
infusion or a pill as an MS you know she
should have her antenna up that the
infusions could have cost a lot more and
she is thinking now of going back to the
pill because she doesn't know if she can
tolerate every why the FDA publishing
that that it's pushing that the cost of
this medication these medications should
be published in commercials and
advertised is but that alone if they
said to her wow this is gonna cost
thirty six hundred dollars what's she
gonna do she's feeling sick her doctor
says you should try it I think we need
just a whole different system because
these drugs are more expensive in this
country thirty thousand dollars more on
average than they are in any other
country in the world so we're being
taken for a ride and not just us but
sick people like Charisse except and
that's not okay by me people know that's
true Elizabeth Rosenthal thank you